hey guys I'm Angie Greenup from love
food and money and today's one minute
monday is make lists here are the
reasons I love making lists and you
should too they motivate you when you
see everything that you need to do right
in front of your face it likes that fire
under your butt to get things done it's
great for time management and
productivity you can really get a sense
of what's important and what's less
important if you put everything down on
a sheet of paper or however you make
your list and you can see it right in
front of you and start to manage your
time on what to do first what to do
second etc etc another reason you should
make list is because it keeps you from
getting overwhelmed there are a lot of
times when I think of something I need
to do and I just get overwhelmed that
it's yet another thing that I have to do
and oh my gosh it I have so much to do
that I can't even focus on what it is
that I have to do if i write it down and
put it in a list form it's so much less
overwhelming i can see it right in front
of me everything i have to do every day
i put in a list another reason to make
list is that it gives you a real sense
of accomplishment when you go to cross
something off nothing feels better than
to take out a sharpie and find something
on your to-do list you just finished
film a video for Evan Carmichael and
cross it off that feels amazing I just
like it's cathartic and I recommend
using a physical notepad to do list not
having your to-do list be on your phone
or on your computer because it'll sit
here on your desk all day it's always
there for you to reference you don't
have to open anything up you don't have
to scroll through your apps to find it
it's always here deleting something off
of your to-do list app does not feel as
good as crossing it off with a sharpie I
guarantee it so those are the reasons i
love using to-do lists and you should
use them to please subscribe to my
channel love food money and of course
subscribe to Evans channel because he's
awesome and most importantly don't
forget believe
make sure to check out my nose letter
yeah got 11 hi I'm Jason j-rod fonseka
of ra's online com and i want to say
Evan Carmichael's newsletter is
consistent fun inspiring XD only
newsletter I prioritize and look forward
to period